Recently I was talking to this guy who told me how years ago, because of a medical condition, he had to give up beer. He had only been a casual beer drinker before this. He'd never really given beer much thought. But now that he couldn't have a beer, he was thinking of beer all the time.
最近我和一个朋友聊天，他告诉我几年前因为身体原因，他不得不戒掉啤酒。在此之前，他只是偶尔喝点啤酒，从来没真正关注过。但现在一旦不能喝了，他却满脑子都是啤酒。
He had a fantasy that went like this. He goes into a bar and he orders a beer. That was the whole thing. It's hard giving things up.
他曾有过这样一个幻想：走进一家酒吧，点上一杯啤酒。就这么简单。放弃一些东西是很难的。
Walter was three, and it was time for him to give up the pacifier. The pacifier was impairing his speech, and so it was time to give it up. And his mom and dad weaned him from it slowly. First, he could only use the pacifier upstairs. Then only upstairs in his room. Then only upstairs in his room, in the bed, though enforcement on the whole bed thing was actually kind of spotty.
沃尔特三岁时，是时候该戒掉安抚奶嘴了。奶嘴影响了他的发音，所以必须戒掉。他的父母慢慢地帮他戒除：起初，他只能在楼上用奶嘴；接着只能在楼上的房间里用；然后只能在楼上的床上用，不过执行起来其实并不严格。
Anyway, finally came the big day. Walter announced he was ready to get rid of the pacifier, and he threw it into the trash himself. And everybody clapped, and everybody hugged him, and then they drove to a toy store and they got him some special presents. A toy tree house, a teddy bear.
总之，大日子终于到了。沃尔特宣布他准备好扔掉奶嘴了，他自己把它扔进了垃圾桶。大家为他鼓掌，拥抱了他，然后开车带他去玩具店买了一些特别的礼物。一个玩具树屋，还有一只泰迪熊。
And that first night, when it was time to sleep, Walter was brave. He was stoic. He went right to bed. And maybe-- I don't know-- five minutes passed before he was out of the bedroom and downstairs, crying. "I'm really sad," he said.
第一天晚上睡觉时，沃尔特很勇敢，表现得很坚强。他直接上床睡觉了。然后——我不知道——过了五分钟，他走出卧室下楼哭了起来。“我真的很伤心，”他说。
His mom and dad asked him if he wanted to play with his new toys for a while. And he tried that and then went back to bed. More sobbing. An hour passes. Two hours.
他的父母问他要不要玩会儿新玩具，他试了一下，然后又回房睡觉了。接着又是抽泣声。一个小时过去了，两个小时过去了。
It breaks his parents' hearts. Frankly, if they still had had the pacifier in the house, they would have caved and given it to him, it was so upsetting.  But he had thrown it into the trash at his grandparents' house. It was gone. And that night, for the first time in his life, Walter slept in his parents' bed. It was the only way that he could actually get to sleep.
这让他的父母心碎不已。坦白说，如果当时家里还有奶嘴，他们肯定会妥协把奶嘴给他，因为他实在太难过了。但他是在祖父母家把奶嘴扔进垃圾桶的，它已经没了。那天晚上，沃尔特有生以来第一次睡在父母的床上。这是他能入睡的唯一办法。
The next night was a little easier. The next a little easier than that.
第二天晚上稍微容易了些。之后一天比一天容易。
Anyway, after a couple of days, Walter announced the special request that he had for all the grown-ups in his life. Grandmas and grandpas, uncles and aunts, the lady next door. He wanted to hear their stories about when they gave up their pacifiers.
总之，几天后，沃尔特向身边的成年人提出了一个特别请求：爷爷奶奶、叔叔阿姨、邻居阿姨，他想听听他们戒掉安抚奶嘴时的故事。
I told this to a friend of mine who gave up drinking a decade ago, how this little boy, Walter, wanted to hear these stories. And she said, man, that's just like AA. Though the problem for Walter, of course, was that no adult really remembers giving up their own pacifier. It's just too long ago, right?
我把这件事告诉了一位十年前戒酒的朋友，我说有个叫沃尔特的小男孩想听这些故事。她说，嘿，那简直就像戒酒互助会（AA）。但沃尔特的问题在于，没有任何成年人真正记得自己戒掉奶嘴的过程。时间太久了，对吧？
So everybody either talked about giving up other stuff that they did remember, like giving up their blankets as little kids. One auntie offered to talk to him about how she quit smoking. But she was warned off that. Or they just made up stories, dramatic stories about giving up their pacifiers to tell Walter.
于是大家要么谈起自己记得住的其他戒掉的东西，比如小时候戒掉毯子。有一位阿姨主动提出跟他说自己怎么戒烟的，但被制止了。或者，他们就干脆编造故事，给沃尔特讲那些关于戒掉奶嘴的戏剧性故事。
It's comforting to hear other people's stories of kicking the habit. It's just comforting at any age. It makes it feel like it's possible. And so this week, we bring you four stories of people giving things up, living without, some of them voluntarily, some not.
听到别人克服习惯的故事是很安慰人的，无论在什么年纪都一样。这让人觉得事情是有可能的。所以本周，我们为您带来四个关于人们放弃某样东西、在生活中失去它们的故事，有些人是自愿的，有些人则不是。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act One of our program today, Do You Hear What I Hear? In that act, one man, one teenage daughter, and many, many fish. Act Two, Yerrrrr Out! The baseball story that no baseball player wants to tell. Act Three, The Call of the Great Indoors, in which we hear a defense of living inside from somebody who can speak authoritatively about the pros and cons. Act Four, Tin Man. In that act, life without a heart. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的第一幕，“你听见我听见的吗？”在那一幕中，有一位父亲、一位十几岁的女儿，还有许多许多的鱼。第二幕，“出局！”这是一段没有棒球运动员愿意讲述的棒球故事。第三幕，“室内大冒险”，在这一幕中，我们听到了某位对室内生活利弊颇有见地的人士所做的辩护。第四幕，“锡人”。在那一幕中，没有心的生活。请继续收听。
Act One, Do You Hear What I Hear? This is a story of being forced to give up one thing, and then giving up another by choice. Nubar Alexanian put it together with his daughter Abby.
第一幕，“你听见我听见的吗？”这是一个关于被迫放弃一样东西，然后又主动放弃另一样东西的故事。努巴尔·亚历山大和他的女儿艾比一起制作了这个节目。
You know, I didn't talk about it for a long time, because it's so abstract. It's like people can't imagine it.
你知道，我很久都没有谈论过它，因为它太抽象了。就像人们根本无法想象一样。
[TONE]
[音调]
But then I'll be in a restaurant. There's a loud din of people talking and dishes, and all that stuff going on in a restaurant. And somebody will ask me, how loud is it right now? And I'll often say, it's the loudest thing in the room. And people can't-- it's just incomprehensible to people that you could get used to a tone like that in your head all the time. See, like, I'm talking about it right now? It's really loud.
但后来我在餐馆里，周围有人们谈话和餐具碰撞的嘈杂声。有人会问我：“现在有多吵？”我通常会说：“这是房间里最大的声音。”人们无法理解，怎么可能习惯脑子里一直有这样的声音。你看，就像我现在谈论它一样？它真的很响。
[TONE]
[音调]
The very first doctor I saw was this young ear, nose, and throat guy. And he examined me. But he was examining me as if he were just going through the motions. He already knew what he was going to tell me. So after all the examinations, he said, well, you have tinnitus, and there's no cure for it.  You're just going to have to learn to live with it.
我见过的第一位医生是个年轻的耳鼻喉科医生。他检查了我，但他检查的样子好像只是走过场。他已经知道要跟我说什么了。所以检查完后，他说：“嗯，你有耳鸣，治不好的。你只能学着与它共处。”
And I thought, what are you talking about? I can't learn to live with this. And I went through 10 years of five other doctors, going to the high priests in Boston hospitals, to every alternative-- psychics-- you can possibly imagine. I mean, there's almost-- I don't think there's anything-- four or five different acupuncturists-- this one dentist said, well, I'm going to make you a mouth guard. He said, well, I'm sure this will work. It's going to cost $19,000. I did some muscle body work and some homeopathic remedies-- I had my entire jaw realigned by a dentist over a two year period. And then we had things like this guy come in who spread these Petri dishes all over our house. So we had to install all these filtering systems in our house, and fans, and air cleaners, and dehumidifiers-- so I've spent, probably over 10 years, $7,000.
我想，你在说什么？我没法学着与这个共处。在那之后的10年里，我看了5位医生，去了波士顿医院的顶级专家那里，尝试了每一种替代疗法——灵媒——你能想象到的。我的意思是，几乎——我不认为还有什么——四五位不同的针灸师——有一位牙医说：“嗯，我给你做一个护齿套。”他说，“我肯定这个会有用。要花19000美元。”我做了肌肉身体矫正和一些顺势疗法——一位牙医在两年内重塑了我的整个下巴。后来还有人把培养皿散布在我们家里，我们不得不安装了各种过滤系统、风扇、空气净化器和除湿机——所以在10年里，我大概花了7000美元。
I'm a photographer, and the first tone appeared around the same time that I started working on this book about musicians called Where Music Comes From. And I travelled around the world with 25 different musicians. And all of a sudden, I had to stop. First tone appeared at the beginning of the project, and then the second tone came, and the whole thing got so bad that my career just came to a stop. I just couldn't travel. I was completely disabled by these tones.
我是名摄影师，第一个音调出现时，正好是我开始制作那本名为《音乐来自何处》的音乐家书籍的时候。我带着25位不同的音乐家环游世界。突然间，我不得不停下来。第一个音调在项目开始时出现，然后是第二个音调，情况变得太糟了，我的职业生涯戛然而止。我无法再旅行了。我完全被这些音调摧毁了。
I'm going to try on the piano. I think what I have on my right ear is a D flat. And in my left ear, a C, one octave lower. The right ear is a D flat, and the left ear is a C.
我要在钢琴上试一下。我觉得我右耳里的是降D音，左耳的是C音，低一个八度。右耳是降D，左耳是C。
The most maddening part of this was when I was with this friend of mine, this jazz musician. And I described it to him. And he threw his head down in his hands on the table. We were having lunch. And I could see in him that he completely understood how maddening it was. Because he understood that the D flat was always trying to resolve itself into the C.
最让人抓狂的部分是，我和一位爵士乐手朋友在一起时，我向他描述了这种感觉。他把头埋在桌子上的双手里。我们当时正在吃午饭。我能感觉到他完全理解那种抓狂感。因为他明白，那个降D音总是试图向C音解析。
So can you play both of them at the same time?
那你能不能同时弹出这两个音？
I might be able to. Let's see. Let me try this for a second.
也许可以。让我看看。让我试一下。
[INCREASINGLY LOUD TONE]
[音量渐强]
Dad?
爸爸？
Test. OK, what were you saying?
测试。好的，你刚才想说什么？
That well, as we've been doing this piece, I've been thinking. It must-- I couldn't imagine having a tone in my ear-- especially like a pure tone-- tones that don't stop like that. So I can not even imagine what it must be like to have it all the time.
我是说，我们在做这个节目的时候，我一直在想。我无法想象耳朵里一直有个音调——尤其是那种纯音——那种不停的音调。所以我真的无法想象那种一直伴随着它的感觉。
So what is it about having the tone?
那么，有这种音调到底是什么感觉？
Like you're trapped inside your own head. You're in a room with no doors and no windows, and just a speaker of that sound driving you literally up the walls. I swear, I would cut my head off or something. I'd follow van Gogh's path and cut my ears off.
就像被困在自己的脑袋里。你待在一个没有门窗的房间里，只有一个扬声器发出那种声音，简直要把你逼疯。我发誓，我可能会切掉脑袋什么的。我会效仿凡·高，切掉耳朵。
Is this is an odd thing to say, you think? I'm somewhat grateful for the tone. Of course, I don't feel grateful on bad days. But you know, before you were born, I used to travel constantly on assignment, all over the world. And on good days, when I think about it, I think about the tone being a warning that I needed to slow down. And then you were born, and I thought, not only did I need to slow down, but I wanted to slow down.
你觉得说这种话很奇怪吗？我对这个音调甚至心存感激。当然，在糟糕的日子里我不会感到感激。但在你出生前，我经常为了工作在世界各地奔波。在顺心的日子里，当我想到它，我会觉得这个音调是一个警示，告诉我需要慢下来。后来你出生了，我想，我不仅需要慢下来，而且我想要慢下来。
And on bad days, I feel like, oh, OK, I've learned this lesson. I've slowed down. Now the tone can go away. But it doesn't go away.
在糟糕的日子里，我觉得，好吧，我学会了这个教训。我已经慢下来了。现在音调可以消失了吧。但它并没有消失。
[TONE]
[音调]
I'm reading through this outline of all the tapes that we have. And you say, I could not imagine losing my hearing. And I was like, well, wait a minute. It's not that bad. And then I realize it's sort of the reverse. I haven't really lived with perfect hearing ever, so I can't compare. But I just thought it was interesting that you couldn't imagine losing your hearing, and I could not imagine having tinnitus.
我正在阅读我们所有磁带的大纲。你说：“我无法想象失去听力。”我当时想，等等，这没那么糟。然后我意识到这其实是反过来的。我从来没有过完美的听力，所以我无法比较。但我只是觉得你无法想象失去听力，而我无法想象患有耳鸣，这很有趣。
Do you remember when you got your hearing aid?
你还记得你什么时候戴上助听器的吗？
No.
不记得。
Do you want to hear what happened?
你想听听当时发生了什么吗？
OK.
好的。
I mean, because for Mom and I, it was like a huge event. Because you'd gone through all of the tests. And we had discovered that you indeed had a hearing loss, and that they were going to fit you with a hearing aid. And before that, you kept saying "what" all the time. And there were certain words that you couldn't pronounce, or certain sounds that you obviously were missing. And that's what the audiologist and the doctors described to us.
对我和妈妈来说，那是一件大事。因为你经历了所有的检查。我们发现你确实有听力损失，他们打算为你配一副助听器。在那之前，你总是说“什么？”。有些词你发不出音，或者有些声音你显然错过了。这就是听力学家和医生向我们描述的情况。
So we went down to Beverly Hospital. And Mom and I were sitting in the room. And she put the hearing aid in your ear, and turned it on, and made all the adjustments. And then you slid off the chair and said, "Oh my god! I can hear."
我们去了贝弗利医院。我和妈妈坐在房间里。她把助听器放进你的耳朵，打开开关，做了所有的调整。然后你从椅子上滑下来，说：“天哪！我能听见了。”
But sometimes I wonder what it would be like to hear everything perfectly. You know? Like to have that entire sound, every, like, aspect of someone's voice. Or music. Every note, to hear every single one. Would be incredible to me. And I don't know what that would be like. I've never known what that would be like.
但有时我想，如果能完美地听到一切会是什么样子？你知道吗？比如拥有完整的音质，听到人声的每一个细节。或者音乐。每一个音符，听到每一个细节。那对我来说太不可思议了。我不知道那是什么感觉。我从来没体会过。
Let's just talk about-- you transcribed my hearing test, where you got to actually hear the sound that's in my ear?
我们谈谈这个吧——你听译了我的听力测试，在那里你真正听到了我耳朵里的声音？
I can't hear one of the tones that you hear.
我听不到你听到的其中一个音调。
So you didn't hear the tone in my right ear?
那你没听到我右耳的音调？
No. I couldn't hear the high one. Because I'm missing that in my-- that's part of my hearing loss. I'm missing that particular frequency in both my ears.
没有。我听不到那个高音。因为我缺失了那部分听力——那是我的听力损失的一部分。我在两只耳朵里都缺失了那个特定的频率。
So you can't hear the sound--
所以你听不到那个声音——
I can't hear the sound that you hear all the time.
我听不到你一直听到的那个声音。
At all?
完全听不到吗？
At all.
完全听不到。
That's incredible, don't you think?
那太不可思议了，你不觉得吗？
I know. It's too much of a coincidence.
我知道。这太巧合了。
I can't be in quiet places. It can be really maddening to be in quiet places. It's the thing, though, that I think is responsible for me taking up fly fishing, because it's the closest I can get to quiet. You know, I'm out there, it's early morning, it's dark. I'm in my boat. I push off into the current. Don't start the engine. The river is waking up, and there are little sounds of birds and stuff going on.
我不能待在安静的地方。待在安静的地方真的会让人抓狂。但我认为这正是让我开始玩飞钓的原因，因为那是我能获得的最接近安静的体验。你知道，我在那里，清晨，天还是黑的。我在船上。我划入水流。不发动引擎。河流正在苏醒，有鸟儿和其他细小的声音。
And then there's me with my fly line, going back and forth and back and forth. And I'm focusing on the fly line, trying to get it out 100 feet. And there is a sound that it makes that I can sort of attach to. And so I'm really focused on that, and it takes me away from the sound in my head. And that's what quiet is to me. That's the most quiet that I can have.
然后是我，挥动着飞钓线，来回甩动。我专注于钓线，试着把它抛出100英尺。它发出一种声音，我可以附着在那上面。所以我非常专注，这让我摆脱了脑子里的声音。那对我来说就是安静。那是我能拥有的最彻底的安静。
Anything else you want to say about it?
还有什么想说的吗？
Just that I think maybe it's taught you patience. Because I didn't know you before you had this, so I wouldn't know. But I would think that it might have taught you something about settling or acceptance. Because I remember you told us this story about how you went to all these doctors. But the first doctor you went to told you there's no cure. You couldn't do anything. And so you spent tons of money seeing a whole bunch of other doctors, who tried a whole bunch of other things. And finally, you just realized that the first doctor was right. And I guess that was probably your acceptance part of it.
只是觉得也许它教会了你耐心。因为在你患上这个之前我不认识你，所以我不知道。但我认为这可能教会了你关于妥协或接受的事情。因为我记得你给我们讲过你找遍了所有医生的故事。但你见的第一位医生告诉你没有治愈方法。你什么也做不了。于是你花了大笔钱去看其他很多医生，尝试了很多其他方法。最后，你只是意识到第一位医生是对的。我想那大概就是你接受现实的过程。
And it's also that you were working so frantically before, and then you got tinnitus, and you had to stop. And I got more of you. Because I do you remember you traveling a lot. And I remember how much you were gone. And I remember asking Mom when you'd come home. But then you came, and you stayed home, and you played with me, and you took me to school every day. And I think that was really good for the family.
还有就是，你之前工作太疯狂了，后来得了耳鸣，不得不停下来。我得到了更多与你相处的时间。因为我记得你经常出差。我记得你离开过那么久。我记得我问妈妈你什么时候回家。但后来你回来了，留在了家里，和我一起玩，每天送我上学。我觉得那对家庭真的很好。
Nubar and Abby Alexanian. They put together that story with Jay Allison for the website Transom.org. If you want to learn how to put together a radio story, they explain how to do it at Transom.org. This story got funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
努巴尔和艾比·亚历山大。他们与杰·艾利森一起为网站 Transom.org 制作了这个故事。如果你想学习如何制作广播故事，他们在那网站上有详细解释。这个故事获得了公共广播公司（CPB）的资助。
Act Two, Yerrrrr Out! At first you don't really think about it, Bobby says. He got drafted to play professional baseball for the Cubs, was sent to the minor leagues, like most players are. And for the first two years, he says, you don't wonder if you're going to make it. You know you're going to make it. For one thing, the evidence is everywhere.
第二幕，“出局！”鲍比说，起初你并不会多想。他被选去为小熊队打职业棒球，像大多数球员一样被送到了小联盟。他说，前两年你不会怀疑自己能否成功。你知道你会成功的。首先，证据随处可见。
You see it all the time. You're in double A, or even in A ball, and somebody does get the call. We had a shortstop when I was with the Reds. His name was Travis Dawkins. His nickname was Gookie Dawkins. And Barry Larkin got hurt in the big leagues. And the phone call came in to the manager's office. And the buzz-- all of a sudden, this buzz started taking over the clubhouse. And it was about Gookie. Gookie is going to the show. And I remember him cleaning out his locker, getting ready to get on the next flight to Cincinnati.
你经常看到。你在 2A 甚至 A 级联赛，确实有人接到了大联盟的征召。我在红人队时有一个游击手，名叫特拉维斯·道金斯，绰号“古基·道金斯”。巴里·拉金在大联盟受伤了。经理办公室接到了电话。然后，一种嗡嗡声——突然间，这种嗡嗡声开始在更衣室蔓延开来。那是关于古基的。古基要进大联盟了。我记得他清理储物柜，准备搭乘下一班去辛辛那提的飞机。
So he's your buddy. And you're watching him clean out his locker to go.
所以他是你的伙伴，你看着他清理储物柜准备离开。
Yeah. And that has happened quite a bit. Quite a bit.
是的。这种情况发生过不少次。相当多。
By his third year, out of the 52 guys Bobby was drafted with, only 15 were still playing ball. In his fourth year he was traded. By his seventh year, he was sitting on the bench a lot. And then he broke his wrist, had a hard time finding a team who would pick him up.
到了第三年，在鲍比被选中的52个人中，只有15个还在打球。第四年他被交易了。第七年，他大部分时间坐在替补席上。然后他摔断了手腕，很难找到愿意签他的球队。
And I think I was pretty rusty. And I was pretty discouraged. I really thought that the time might be sooner than later than I was out of the game. There were quite a bit of people that said, is this it? Can you go back? And the questions started coming, and more regularly as I continued to play.
我觉得自己很生疏，也很气馁。我真的觉得我离开球场的时间可能指日可待。有不少人问，这就结束了吗？还能回去吗？随着我继续打球，这些问题越来越频繁地出现。
How would people say it? Were they sheepish about it, or they just didn't even know to be sheepish about it?
别人是怎么说的？他们是感到羞涩，还是根本不知道该怎么表现才不那么尴尬？
I wish they were sheepish about it, frankly. It's frustrating when people would ask-- I was always very uncomfortable when people would ask me those type of questions.
坦白说，我希望他们能表现得羞涩一点。当人们问那些类型的问题时，我很沮丧——我一直对此感到很不自在。
But then his season improved. He actually went on a kind of streak.
但后来他的赛季表现好转了。他甚至进入了一个连胜状态。
I had a few games in particular where I thought, I can do this. I'm a major league ballplayer. I can swing a baseball bat with anybody who plays the game. I had one game in particular, I think I was four for five, and hit two home runs, and knocked in seven runs. And when you get on those hot streaks, those are times when you really think, I'm right there. You know? Somebody goes down. They need a good left-handed hitter off the bench. I've got a phone call tomorrow.
我有几场比赛表现特别好，心想，我能做到。我是大联盟球员。我可以和任何打球的人一样挥棒。其中一场比赛，我大概5个打数4安打，打了两个全垒打，贡献了7分打点。当你处于那种火热状态时，你会觉得，我就在那儿。你知道吗？有人表现不佳。他们需要一个好的左手代打。明天我就会接到电话。
And that's what keeps somebody going in this situation. There had always been so much proof, you know? He had been a high school star, an all-state, and a college star, and all Big Ten. And his brother, Hal Morris, was playing for the Reds. And it's like what happens in a casino. You win enough of the time to keep you going, to keep you in the game. It feels like the big win is right around the corner.
这就是支撑一个人在这种情况下继续前进的动力。一直以来都有太多证据，你知道的。他是高中明星，全州明星，大学明星，入选过大十联盟。他的兄弟哈尔·莫里斯在为红人队效力。这就好比赌场里的情况。你赢的次数足够多，足以让你坚持下去，留在比赛中。感觉大赢就在拐角处。
What got Bobby to finally quit was that that vision of his future was replaced with a different vision of who he might become. At the beginning of his 10th year, he couldn't get onto an affiliated team. He went to the independent leagues, a step down. And when he showed up for spring training and looked around at the other guys, he thought to himself, he was seeing a lot of guys who had hung on for too long. And he wondered if that's who he was becoming.
让鲍比最终决定退出的原因，是他对未来的展望被另一种对他可能成为什么样的人的构想所取代。第10年开始时，他没能进入任何附属球队。他去了独立联盟，那是更低的一级。当他参加春训，环顾四周时，他心想，他看到了很多在那儿蹉跎了太久的人。他怀疑那是不是自己正在变成的样子。
And during one of their very first practice games, he suddenly found he'd decided.
在最初的几场练习赛中，他突然发现自己做出了决定。
My last at bat. I know I got three at bats. I ground it out to second base, and I did know. I knew that was it. Certainly. I think the moment the ball was off my bat, I had a thought that this might be the last one. And I ran by. The throw beat me by a couple of steps. And I kept running as far as I can through the bag. And I just kind of kept going out to the outfield a little bit.
我最后一次上场。我知道我打了三个打数。我敲出一个滚地球被传杀到二垒，我就知道了。我确定那就是最后一次了。那一刻，球离开球棒时，我心里想这可能是最后一个打数了。我跑了过去。传球比我快了几步。我跑过一垒包，顺势多跑了一段距离进入外场。
I remember thinking after, as I'm decelerating down the baseline, just thinking, well, if this is my last one, it's kind of apropos, because I gave it everything I had. I ran down to first with everything I had. And it just wasn't enough to get me there in time.
我记得当时在沿跑垒线减速时，心里想着，好吧，如果这是我最后一次上场，那也挺贴切的，因为我付出了我所有的一切。我竭尽全力跑向一垒。只是没能及时赶到。
For years, he had been wrestling with his decision. And then it was done. He went to the batting cage, he hit for a while, and then he told his coaches.
多年来，他一直在纠结自己的决定。然后一切都结束了。他去了打击笼练习了一会儿，然后告诉了他的教练。
What was it like for you after you decided?
决定之后你的感觉如何？
It was very difficult. I would say that there was a prolonged grieving process. It was tough. For years, I still wanted to tell people-- when they asked, what do you do-- I'd say, I'm a baseball player. That was just how I identified myself. And when all that was done, when that final realization was there, it was like the amputated leg. I still felt it afterwards for a long time.
非常困难。我想说有一个漫长的悲伤过程。很难受。多年后，当别人问我是做什么的，我还是想说：“我是个棒球运动员。”那是我的自我认同方式。当一切结束，当那最后的现实到来时，感觉就像截肢了一样。很长一段时间里，我还能感觉到它的存在。
Were you able to watch baseball?
你能看棒球比赛吗？
No. I wouldn't watch any baseball for a good year and a half after I left. I didn't watch any in 2002. And frankly, I don't think I watched any in 2003. I went back, and my dad still liked to watch baseball. And we'd put the Cubs game on. And after about a half an inning or an inning, I'd see a lot of guys I played with or played against. And I stopped. Go downstairs and do something else.
不能。离开后的一年半里我都不看棒球。2002年我不看，坦白说，2003年我大概也没看。我回到家，我父亲还喜欢看棒球。我们打开小熊队的比赛。过了一半局数或一局后，我会看到很多我一起打过球或对抗过的球员。我就停下来，下楼去做别的事情。
It was very difficult. You see these players. You want to play the if game and the if-then. And this guy is not as good as I am, and why is he there? Now, I'm absolutely fine with it. But for years, I didn't want anything to do with baseball.
这太难了。你看着那些球员。你想玩“如果”游戏，如果我怎样怎样。这个人没我打得好，为什么他在那儿？现在，我完全没问题了。但多年来，我不想跟棒球有任何瓜葛。
See, I think one of the things that would be hard in your situation is if you have this dream and this identity that's driving you for so long, and from such a young age, it's sort of like you can't replace something with nothing. You've got to replace something with something else.
你看，我觉得在你的处境中，困难的一点是如果你有这样一个长期驱动着你、且从很小年纪就扎根的梦想和身份，你不能用虚无来取代。你必须用别的东西来取代它。
Absolutely. You know, I'm a commodities trader. And one of the things I love about what I do is the day in, day out process is the same. You fall into routines. You get up early. I watch Bloomberg every morning for 15 minutes before I go take a shower. And then I've got a routine that I read the newspaper on the way to the office. When I'm in the office, I prepare for the day in the same way. And then it's another highly competitive, dog-eat-dog world. And I like that.
绝对是这样。你知道，我是个大宗商品交易员。我热爱这份工作的一点是，日复一日的流程都是一样的。你陷入常规。你早起。我每天早上在去洗澡前看15分钟的彭博电视。然后我有一套习惯，在去办公室的路上读报纸。在办公室里，我以同样的方式准备工作。那是一个高度竞争、弱肉强食的世界。我喜欢那样。
And also you know when you've won. You know when you've lost.  There is a tally at the end of the day. You have your stats.
而且你知道什么时候赢了，什么时候输了。每天结束时都有一个结算。你有你的数据。
Absolutely. Absolutely. And I just am able to have that same tunnel vision like I did when I played. Guys are always amazed that when I first got into the trading business, I would come in at 2:00 in the morning when the European markets closed. And I would sometimes trade until 3:00, 4:00 in the afternoon. I'd sit down there for 14 straight hours and trade.
绝对是。我能拥有和打球时一样的专注力。当我刚进入交易行业时，同事们都很惊讶，我会因为欧洲市场收盘而在凌晨2点来到公司。有时我会交易到下午3点、4点。我会坐在那里连续交易14个小时。
I love the concentration. I love having to focus and having to be on top of your game every day. Because I had to do something like that. I had to do something where there were stakes at hand, and that there was winning and there was losing.
我喜欢这种专注。我喜欢必须保持专注、每天都处于巅峰状态。因为我必须做点什么。我必须做一件有风险的事情，有输赢的事情。
Bobby Morris. He and I recorded that interview back in 2005. He spent another few years after that as a full-time commodities trader in Chicago. Then in 2007, he left the city and moved back to his home state of Indiana. He still works as a trader part-time. But a few years ago, Bobby went back to baseball, this time in a new way, working with kids. He's a teacher at the White Sox Youth Academy and a coach for competitive travel teams. Focusing on the young players, he says, on helping them improve, watching them improve, helped him remember what he loved about baseball in the first place. He says he's enjoying the game for the first time in years.
鲍比·莫里斯。我和他是在2005年录制的那次采访。此后他又在芝加哥做了几年全职大宗商品交易员。2007年，他离开那座城市，回到了家乡印第安纳州。他现在还是兼职做交易员。但几年前，鲍比以一种新的方式回到了棒球界，那就是与孩子们一起工作。他是白袜青年学院的老师，也是竞争性旅行球队的教练。他说，专注于年轻球员，帮助他们进步、看着他们进步，让他记起了自己当初热爱棒球的原因。他说，这是他多年来第一次真正享受这项运动。
Act Three, The Call of the Great Indoors. There are some kinds of living without that is really hard for most of us to fathom. In Boston, Chelsea Merz has been talking with somebody about one of those.
第三幕，“室内大冒险”。有些生活方式，是我们大多数人难以理解的。在波士顿，切尔西·默茨一直在和某人谈论这些事。
The first thing I noticed about Matthew were his fingernails. They're so clean, much cleaner than mine. And I am humbled. I have no excuse. Unlike Matthew, I have not been living on the streets for seven years.
我注意到马修的第一件事是他的手指甲。它们非常干净，比我的干净多了。我感到很惭愧。我没有借口。不像马修，我并没有流落街头七年。
Every Saturday, we meet for lunch at Bertucci's, which is this family style Italian restaurant. Every week we sit at the same table. And every time, our waitress assures us that we've made it in time for the lunch special. We will get free refills on soft drinks, a complimentary garden salad, and a basket of rolls.
每个星期六，我们都会在 Bertucci's 共进午餐，那是一家家庭风格的意大利餐厅。每周我们都坐在同一张桌子旁。每次服务员都会向我们保证，我们赶上了午餐特惠。我们将获得免费续杯的软饮、一份免费的田园沙拉和一篮面包卷。
One time, Matthew showed up 20 minutes late. And the manager was giving him a hard time. He was saying, you better make it up to her and buy lunch today. And when we got to our table, Matthew was laughing. And he said, he doesn't know I'm homeless. He has no idea.
有一次，马修晚到了20分钟。经理对他态度很不好。他说：“你最好补偿她一下，今天请吃午餐。”当我们走到座位时，马修在笑。他说：“他不知道我是无家可归的。他一点都不知道。”
And even though Matthew is carrying a large cardboard box, a messenger bag, and two bookbags, he looks more like a college professor. He's clean. He's tidy. He's organized. He is incredibly polite. Every week Matthew tells these stories. So every week I record him.
尽管马修带着一个大纸箱、一个邮差包和两个书包，但他看起来更像是一位大学教授。他干净、整洁、有条理。他非常有礼貌。每周马修都会讲这些故事。所以我每周都录下他的话。
There was this time. It rained nonstop. And when that happens, the shelters just fill up. And there were like 10 of us waiting for two hours. Eventually people start talking. Oh, where were you yesterday, when it started raining? Oh, I was over here. Did you get in somewhere last night?  No, I was outside. Or I went under a bridge.
有次雨下个不停。当这种情况发生时，避难所就会爆满。当时有10个人等了两个小时。最终大家开始交谈。“哦，昨天开始下雨的时候你在哪儿？”“哦，我在这边。”“你昨晚找到地方住了吗？”“没有，我在外面。或者我钻到了桥下。”
So everybody's talking about these things. And one guy in the room was very quiet. Someone started talking to him. What did you do? What did you do yesterday? He has this very thick Spanish accent and doesn't speak English very well. He told us he didn't know Boston at all. He had just arrived from New York. He didn't know the streets. He didn't know where to go.
每个人都在谈论这些事。屋里有个人很安静。有人开始跟他说话。“你做了什么？昨天你做了什么？”他有很浓重的西班牙口音，英语说得不好。他告诉我们他根本不了解波士顿。他刚从纽约来。他不认识路。他不知道去哪儿。
And when it came time-- what about you? Where did you stay? "Alley." The alley? Oh, just the next block? "Yeah, one block. One block." You only got as far as one block, and then you went into the alley. "Si, si." Oh, wow. So where did you sleep in the alley? Was there any place you could sleep underneath or something? He said something like "box."
当轮到他时——“那你呢？你住在哪里？”“小巷。”“小巷？哦，就在隔壁街区吗？”“是的，一个街区。一个街区。”“你只走了一个街区，然后就钻进小巷里去了？”“是的，是的。”“哦，哇。那你睡在小巷的哪里？有什么地方可以让你睡在下面之类的吗？”他说了一些类似“盒子”的东西。
Box? You slept in a box? "Si, si." Well, a cardboard box? Wouldn't it be soaking wet? "Not cardboard. Metal." Metal? You slept in a metal box? And someone said, oh, a dumpster. You slept in a dumpster. "No, no."
“盒子？你睡在盒子里？”“是的，是的。”“嗯，是纸箱吗？难道不会被淋透吗？”“不是纸箱。金属。”“金属？你睡在金属盒子里？”有人说：“哦，垃圾箱。你睡在垃圾箱里。”“不，不。”
Did you get any sleep? "No, no. No sleep. I was afraid." Afraid? You were afraid. "Si, si." What were you afraid of, that somebody might come and beat you up, mug you? "No, no. Button." Button?
“你睡着了吗？”“没有，没有。没睡觉。我很害怕。”“害怕？你很害怕。”“是的，是的。”“你怕什么，怕有人过来打你、抢劫你？”“不，不。按钮。”“按钮？”
And all of a sudden, it occurred to me. And I just said, oh. You didn't sleep in a dumpster. You slept in a trash compacter. "Si, si." You were afraid somebody was going to come and maybe push a button. "Si, si."
突然间，我明白了。我脱口而出：“哦。你没睡在垃圾箱里。你睡在垃圾压缩机里。”“是的，是的。”“你怕有人会过来可能按下按钮。”“是的，是的。”
And when I heard that, I was like at a new level in my feelings and understanding of this whole thing. You're afraid somebody might come to push the button, and you'll die a horrible death.
听到这些时，我对这件事的感受和理解达到了一个新的高度。你害怕有人会过来按下按钮，然后你会死得非常惨。
Once or twice a year, he gets to housesit for an old friend. Around Christmas, he got an offer to housesit for more than two weeks. I met him for lunch the day that ended, and he was back on the street. I wanted to know what it was for him to have a comfortable place to sleep for a change. Usually, he can't count on any of his regular spots. And sometimes he has to stay up all night in a Kinko's or a Dunkin' Donuts.
每年一两次，他能帮一位老朋友看管房子。圣诞节前后，他得到了一个帮人看管两周以上房子的机会。那次结束的那天我和他共进午餐，他又回到了街头。我想知道，对他来说，偶尔能有一个舒适的睡觉地方是什么感觉。通常，他无法依赖任何固定的地点。有时他不得不通宵待在复印店或甜甜圈店里。
Sleep is such a large part of the whole experience of being homeless. I should say sleeplessness. You never get enough sleep. You're so tired so much of the time.
睡眠在无家可归的整个经历中占据很大一部分。我应该说失眠。你永远睡不够。大部分时间里你都太累了。
So what was it like your first night indoors? What was it like to sleep?
所以你第一次在室内睡觉是什么感觉？是什么感觉？
The first night is the best, because you know you've got 16 consecutive nights of uninterrupted living indoors again. Of being able to come over to this apartment, open the door, unlock it with the key, open the door, go over to the sofa-- this nice, huge, comfortable, soft sofa with like eight large pillows. In front of the TV set, with a remote control and everything.
第一晚是最棒的，因为你知道你又有了连续16晚的室内生活。能够来到这个公寓，打开门，用钥匙解锁，打开门，走到沙发旁——这张漂亮、宽大、舒适、柔软的沙发，上面有八个大枕头。在电视机前，有遥控器等等。
It's like what Jean Valjean experienced in the 1935 version of the film Les Miserables with Fredric March as Jean Valjean. After all those years in the prison, the galley slave prison system, whatever, he's released finally. I think it was 14 years, or something, in which he was sleeping on hard surfaces. And when he is finally shown the room where he's going to get to stay, when it's time for him to go to sleep, he looks at the bed.
这就像让·瓦尔让在1935年版电影《悲惨世界》（弗雷德里克·马奇饰）中的经历。在服了那么多年苦役之后，无论是什么监狱系统，他最终被释放了。我想是14年左右，他一直睡在坚硬的表面上。当他最终被带到那个可以住下的房间时，当他要睡觉时，他看着那张床。
And in the years before I was homeless, whenever I'd see this film, I never noticed this. He's looking at the bed. That bed, it's like it's a soft surface, a soft mattress. It's a bed. He hasn't slept in a bed for like 14 years. And when he plops down in it, he leans back. He stretches out. If I remember correctly, his eyes close, as he's savoring the comfort.
而在我无家可归之前的岁月里，每当我看这部电影，我从没注意过这一幕。他看着床。那张床，那是个柔软的表面，一张柔软的床垫。那是一张床。他大概14年没睡过床了。当他扑上去时，他向后躺下。他伸展身体。如果我没记错，他闭上眼睛，正在享受那份舒适。
That's what it's like. That's what it feels like. That's what it felt like the first night I was in there, for these 16 nights in a row.
就是那种感觉。那种感觉。这就是我那连续16晚睡在里面时的感觉。
This is an excerpt from a radio project that Chelsea Merz and Matthew have worked on for years. When we first broadcast that story in 2004, Matthew had been on the street for seven years. He has now gotten off the streets, and gives talks around the country about his experience. You can find more at his website, openchurches.org.
这是切尔西·默茨和马修合作多年的广播项目片段。我们在2004年首次播出那个故事时，马修已经流落街头七年了。他现在已经脱离了街头生活，在全国各地讲述他的经历。你可以在他的网站 openchurches.org 上找到更多内容。
Coming up. Which is more dangerous to your health, heart disease or your own family? Answers in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将播出。对你的健康来说，哪一个更危险：心脏病还是你的家人？节目继续，芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台将在稍后为您解答。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, two weeks into the new year, stories of giving things up, living without, voluntarily or not.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目在新年两周后播出，主题是关于放弃某样东西、失去它们，无论是自愿还是被迫。
We have arrived at Act Four of our program. Act Four, Tin Man. Sometimes you give up something and you're not sure if it's your own idea or not. As in this next story, a short story by Judy Budnitz, read for us by actor Matt Malloy.
节目进入了第四幕。第四幕，“锡人”。有时你放弃了某样东西，但你并不确定这是不是你自己的主意。就像接下来的这个短故事，由朱迪·巴德尼茨创作，演员马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
"What kind of son are you?" asks Aunt Fran. Aunt Nina says, "Your own flesh and blood." "What your mother wouldn't do for you," Aunt Fran goes on. "She'd do anything for you. Anything in the world. And now you won't give just a little back." "For shame!" says Aunt Nina. The heat is stifling, but she pulls her sweater closer.
“你是哪种儿子啊？”弗兰阿姨问道。尼娜阿姨说：“你是她的亲骨肉啊。”“你妈为你做的事还少吗？”弗兰阿姨继续说，“她会为你做任何事。世界上任何事。而现在你连一点点回报都不肯给。”“真丢人！”尼娜阿姨说。天气闷热，但她还是把毛衣裹得更紧了。
We're sitting in the hospital waiting room, Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina and I. My mother suffered a heart attack this morning. We're waiting to see her, the aunts and I.
我们坐在医院候诊室里，弗兰阿姨、尼娜阿姨和我。我母亲今天早上心脏病发作了。我们等着看她，阿姨们和我。
The doctor told us her heart won't last much longer. "We can't fix it," the doctors said. "She needs a new one. A transplant." "Well, then give her one!" the aunts cried. "It's not that easy," said the doctors. "We need a donor."
医生告诉我们她的心脏撑不了多久了。“我们修不好，”医生说，“她需要一颗新的。移植。”“那就给她换一个啊！”阿姨们大叫道。“没那么容易，”医生说，“我们需要捐赠者。”
The doctors went away. The aunts looked at me. "Arnie?" Nina said. "What about your heart?"
医生走了。阿姨们看着我。“阿尼？”尼娜说，“你的心脏怎么样？”
"My heart?" I shouted. "Are you crazy?"
“我的心脏？”我大喊，“你们疯了吗？”
That started them both off on what a bad son I was. It's impossible to argue with Nina, especially with Fran to back her up. I sit in the middle. Aunt Fran clutches one arm, Aunt Nina the other. They wept at first, but now they sit grimly.
那话让她们俩开始指责我是一个多么糟糕的儿子。和尼娜争论是不可能的，尤其是还有弗兰帮腔的时候。我坐在中间。弗兰阿姨抓住一只胳膊，尼娜阿姨抓住另一只。她们起初在哭，但现在坐得很严肃。
A Styrofoam cup of coffee steams next to my foot, but I can't reach for it. The aunts don't care. They're amazed that I bought it, amazed that I could even think of coffee at a time like this.
一杯泡沫塑料杯装的咖啡在我脚边冒着热气，但我够不到。阿姨们不在乎。她们很惊讶我竟然买了咖啡，惊讶我在这种时候竟然还能想到咖啡。
Aunt Fran wears a bally sweater and sensible shoes. Her lips are pressed tight. She taps her feet nervously. On my other side, Nina licks her lips, again and again.
弗兰阿姨穿着一件过时的毛衣和一双舒适的鞋子。她的嘴唇紧抿着。她不安地跺着脚。在另一边，尼娜不停地舔着嘴唇。
"I saw it on 60 Minutes, " Aunt Fran announces. "They put the heart in a cooler, a regular Igloo cooler, like we have at home. And they rush it in a helicopter to the hospital. And they put it in, connect up the pipes. It's just like plumbing."
“我在《60分钟》节目里看到过，”弗兰阿姨宣布，“他们把心脏放在冷却器里，那种我们家里用的那种普通冷藏箱。然后用直升机急送到医院。接上管道。就像修水管一样。”
"You must be your mother's tissue type, too. I'm sure you are," Aunt Nina puts in. "You're young. You're strong. You have a college education. Your heart is exactly what she needs." "You shouldn't have started smoking, though," Aunt Fran goes on. "It's so bad for the heart. You should have thought of that when you started."
“你一定和你母亲的组织类型一样。我肯定你是，”尼娜阿姨插嘴说，“你年轻。你强壮。你有大学文凭。你的心脏正是她需要的。”“不过你不该开始抽烟，”弗兰阿姨接着说，“那对心脏太糟糕了。你开始抽烟的时候就该想到这点。”
"But what about me?" I blurt out finally. "That's what we're talking about. We're talking about your heart," Nina says. "But what happens to me?" I say again. "I can't believe he's thinking of himself at a time like this," Aunt Fran sniffs. "I need my heart. You want me to die so my mother can live?"
“那我呢？”我终于冲口而出。“我们在谈论的就是这个。我们在谈论你的心脏，”尼娜说。“但我怎么办？”我再次问道。“真不敢相信他在这时候只想着自己，”弗兰阿姨轻蔑地说，“我需要我的心脏。你们是想让我死，让我妈妈活吗？”
"Of course we don't want that," says Aunt Fran. "Sylvie loves you so much. She'd want to die herself if you died." "We can't both have my heart," I say.
“我们当然不希望那样，”弗兰阿姨说，“西尔维那么爱你。如果你死了，她自己也不想活了。”“我们不可能共用我的心脏，”我说。
"Of course not," says Nina. "You can get one of those monkey hearts, or that artificial heart they made such a fuss about in the news a while back." "Why can't mother get one of those? Or a transplant from someone else?"
“当然不可能，”尼娜说，“你可以弄一颗猴心，或者新闻里前阵子吵得沸沸扬扬的那种人造心脏。”“为什么妈妈不能用那种？或者别人的移植心脏？”
"Do you want your mother should have a stranger's heart? Or a monkey's heart? Your poor mother. Do you remember how she never used to take you to the zoo because she couldn't stand to see the filthy monkeys? And you want her to have a monkey's heart? It would kill her." Fran cries.
“你难道想让你母亲拥有一颗陌生人的心脏吗？还是猴子的心？可怜的母亲。你还记得她从不带你去动物园，因为她忍受不了看到那些肮脏的猴子吗？而你想让她拥有一颗猴心？那会害死她的。”弗兰哭道。
"She's so weak. She needs a heart that will agree with her," Aunt Nina adds. "Any heart but yours just wouldn't do. But you, you can handle anything. You're young. You're strong. You--"
“她太虚弱了。她需要一颗和她匹配的心脏，”尼娜阿姨补充说，“除了你的，其他的都不行。但你，你可以处理任何事情。你年轻。你强壮。你……”
"Have a college education?" I finished for her.
“有大学文凭？”我替她说完。
Aunt Nina glares and says, "Your mother worked herself to the bone for you so you could go to college and make something of yourself. And now what do you do? Out of college four years already, all you do is sit in front of a typewriter all day, call yourself a writer. Smoking those cigarettes, never get a haircut."
尼娜阿姨怒视着我，说：“你母亲为你呕心沥血，让你去上大学，出人头地。现在你做了什么？大学毕业四年了，整天就坐在打字机前，自称作家。抽着那些香烟，从不理发。”
"And the first time your mother needs you," Aunt Fran finishes, "you turn your back on her." They both tighten their grips on my arm.
“你母亲第一次需要你时，”弗兰阿姨总结道，“你却背弃了她。”她们俩抓我胳膊抓得更紧了。
"I do things for Mother all the time," I begin. One of the doctors appears at the end of the hall. As he approaches, my aunts rise, pulling me with them. "Is she all right?" demands Fran, when he's still 20 feet away. "We've found a donor," Nina announces.
“我一直为母亲做事情，”我刚开始说。一个医生出现在走廊尽头。当他靠近时，阿姨们站起来，把我一起拉起来。“她还好吗？”弗兰问道，他还在20英尺远时。尼娜宣布说：“我们找到捐赠者了。”
The doctor greets us. He's a small man, completely bald. The eyes behind thick glasses are sad. He strokes his scalp as he talks, savoring the feel of it. "She's all right. She's being monitored," he says. "We will look for a donor, but there's a long waiting list."
医生跟我们打招呼。他是个个子矮小、完全秃顶的人。厚眼镜后的眼睛很忧郁。他说话时摸着头皮，仿佛在享受那种触感。“她很好。正在接受监控，”他说，“我们会寻找捐赠者，但等待名单很长。”
"We've got a donor. Sylvie's son. He's in the prime of health," Aunt Nina says. "This is Arnie," Fran explains.
“我们有捐赠者了。西尔维的儿子。他正值壮年，”尼娜阿姨说，“这是阿尼，”弗兰解释道。
The doctor studies me carefully. "Surely you don't do that sort of thing?" I say incredulously. He gazes at me. "It's very rare, very rare indeed that a son will be so good as to donate his heart. In a few cases, it has been done. But it's so rare to find such a son, a rare and beautiful thing."
医生仔细打量着我。“你们肯定不会做那种事吧？”我难以置信地问。他凝视着我。“很难得，真的很难得，竟然有儿子会如此善良愿意捐出心脏。在极少数情况下，有人做过。但找到这样的儿子太难得了，这真是一件罕见而美妙的事情。”
He takes off his glasses and polishes them on his sleeve. Without them, his eyes are small, piggish. He puts them back on, and his eyes are sad and soulful once more. "You must love your mother very much," he says. "Oh, he does," Fran says. I shift my feet and knock over the cup of coffee and it spills on the floor, a sudden ugly brownness spreading over the empty white.
他摘下眼镜，在袖子上擦了擦。没有眼镜，他的眼睛显得又小又像猪眼。他又戴上眼镜，眼睛又变得忧郁而深邃了。“你一定非常爱你母亲，”他说。“噢，他当然爱，”弗兰说。我挪动双脚，打翻了那杯咖啡，它洒在地板上，空荡荡的白色地面上突然蔓延出一片难看的褐色。
A nurse leads us to the intensive care unit, where my mother is lying attached to machines and bags of fluid. Aunt Fran rushes to one side of the bed, Aunt Nina the other. I shuffle awkwardly at the foot of the bed. I touch my mother's feet.
护士领我们去了重症监护室，我母亲躺在那里，身上连着各种机器和输液袋。弗兰阿姨冲向床的一边，尼娜阿姨冲向另一边。我在床脚尴尬地挪动着。我摸了摸我母亲的脚。
"Sylvie, are you all right?" The aunts cry. My mother opens her eyes. There are purple circles around them. She looks pale, but not so different from usual. Hardly on the verge of death. She smiles dully at her sisters. "Oh, Sylvie. You look wonderful, just the same," they say.
“西尔维，你还好吗？”阿姨们哭道。我母亲睁开眼睛。眼睛周围有一圈紫色。她看起来很苍白，但和平常没太大区别。根本不像濒死的样子。她迟钝地向她的姐妹们笑了笑。“噢，西尔维。你看上去棒极了，一点都没变，”她们说。
Then she raises her eyes to me. "Oh, Arnie. You look terrible," she says. "That jacket. I told you to throw it away. I'll find you another. There's no reason to go around looking like a mess."
然后她抬起眼睛看向我。“噢，阿尼。你看上去糟透了，”她说，“那件夹克。我让你把它扔掉。我会给你找另一件。没有理由把自己搞得像个乱糟糟的人一样。”
"Arnie has some good news," Nina says. "Then why does he look like a thundercloud?" says my mother. "Arnie, is something bothering you?"
“阿尼有个好消息，”尼娜说。“那他为什么看起来像朵乌云？”我母亲说，“阿尼，有什么事烦着你吗？”
Fran says, "Arnie wants to give you his heart." "I never said that," I cry. There is a pause.
弗兰说：“阿尼想把他的心脏给你。”“我从来没说过，”我大叫道。沉默了一会儿。
"Of course, Arnie, you shouldn't. You don't need to do that for me. Really, you don't," my mother says. She looks terribly sad. The aunts' faces have gone stony. "I never expected anything from you, you know. Of course, nothing like this."
“当然，阿尼，你不应该这样做。你没必要为我做那种事。真的，不用，”我母亲说。她看起来非常难过。阿姨们的脸变得像石头一样。“我从没指望过你什么，你知道的。当然，也没想到会是这种事。”
I look down at her feet, two motionless humps under the blanket. "I'm considering it, Mother. Really, I am. I want to find out more about it before I decide. That's all. It's not as simple as changing a car battery or something." I force out a laugh.
我低头看着她的脚，毯子下那两团一动不动的凸起。“我在考虑，母亲。真的，我在考虑。我想在决定之前了解更多信息。仅此而已。这不像换汽车电池什么的。”我强挤出一丝笑。
No one else laughs, but the aunts' faces melt a little. My heart is is pounding. My mother closes her eyes. "You're a good boy, Arnie," she says. "Your father would be proud."
没人跟着笑，但阿姨们的脸色缓和了一些。我的心在狂跳。我母亲闭上了眼睛。“你是个好孩子，阿尼，”她说，“你父亲会为你感到自豪的。”
A nurse comes in and tells us that we should let my mother rest for a while. Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina head back to the waiting room. I walk up and down the halls of dull white where patients shuffle in slow motion, wheeling their IVs along beside them. I can feel in the floor the buzzing vibration of motors churning away somewhere in the heart of the building. I take the elevator and wander until I find a pay phone.
护士进来告诉我们，应该让母亲休息一会儿。弗兰阿姨和尼娜阿姨回候诊室了。我沿着枯燥的白色走廊来回踱步，病人们缓缓地走动，旁边推着输液架。我能感觉到地板里传来的嗡嗡震动，那是建筑心脏部位的马达在轰鸣。我乘电梯四处游荡，直到找到一台公用电话。
I call up Mandy. She picks up on the first ring. "Hi," she says. "Where have you been?"
我给曼迪打电话。她第一声就接了。“嗨，”她说，“你一直在哪儿呢？”
"My mother had a heart attack this morning," I say. "I'm at the hospital."
“我妈今天早上心脏病发作了，”我说，“我在医院。”
"Oh, I knew this would happen," Mandy says. "I burned my hand on the radiator this morning, and right away I thought, uh oh, an omen. Something bad's going to happen. How old's your mother?"
“噢，我就知道会这样，”曼迪说，“今天早上我被暖气片烫伤了手，立刻就想，哦不，是个征兆。肯定有什么坏事要发生了。你妈妈多大了？”
"57," I say.
“57，”我说。
"Oh, that's young for a heart attack. And she wasn't fat or anything. I feel like it's my fault. I should have warned you or something."
“噢，心脏病发作来说这太年轻了。而且她又不胖什么的。我觉得是我的错。我本应该提醒你或者什么的。”
Finally, I ask her to come to the hospital. And she says all right and hangs up. I don't need to tell her where to go. Mandy never gets lost. She never has to wait in line. Strangers on the street talk to her. Jobs fall in her lap. She's nice looking, freckles on her nose, good straight teeth. She keeps telling me that my signs indicate my life will be on a big upswing soon, and that I'm just in a transition period right now. I hope she's right.
最后，我请求她来医院。她说好，然后挂了电话。我不需要告诉她去哪里。曼迪从来不会迷路。她从不需要排队。街上的陌生人都会跟她说话。工作自动送上门。她长得不错，鼻子上有雀斑，牙齿洁白整齐。她一直告诉我，我的迹象表明我的生活很快就会迎来大转机，我现在正处于转型期。希望她是正确的。
I finally reach the lobby, and just as I do, Mandy comes bursting in the doors, beaming at me. She doesn't smile. She beams. "I knew I'd find you," she says. "How's your mother? Have you seen her?" Her breath in my face is like pine trees and toothpaste.
我终于到了大厅，就在这时，曼迪冲了进来，光芒四射地看着我。她不是在微笑。她是光芒四射。“我就知道能找到你，”她说，“你妈妈怎么样？你见到她了吗？”她呼出的气息扑在我脸上，带着松木和牙膏的味道。
"Yes, she's all right for now. Come on. Let's go outside for a minute. I want to ask you something."
“是的，她暂时没事。来吧，我们出去一会儿。我想问你点事。”
Outside, the afternoon is darkening to early evening. We wander in the parking lot among the cars, talking softly like we're afraid we'll wake them. It's cold. I keep looking back to see if anyone is following us.
外面，下午的天色正变得昏暗。我们在停车场里漫步，穿梭在汽车之间，轻声交谈，仿佛怕吵醒它们。天很冷。我不停回头看是否有人跟着我们。
"They say my mother's heart is bad," I tell Mandy. "She needs a new one. They want me to donate my heart. What do you think of that?"
“他们说我母亲的心脏坏了，”我告诉曼迪，“她需要一颗新的。他们想让我捐出我的心脏。你觉得怎么样？”
Mandy stops, her eyes and mouth open. Wind whips her frizzy hair around her face. She looks shocked. I breathe a sigh of relief. At last, someone who can see reason.
曼迪停住脚步，瞪大双眼张着嘴。风卷着她那蓬松的头发扑在脸上。她看起来很震惊。我松了一口气。终于有个懂道理的人了。
But then she says, "Oh, Arnie. How wonderful. Can they really do that? That's so wonderful. Congratulations!"
但随后她说：“噢，阿尼。太美好了。他们真的能做到吗？那太美好了。祝贺你！”
"You mean you think I should do it?"
“你的意思是，你觉得我应该去做？”
"Isn't technology incredible?" Mandy says. "These days doctors can do anything. Now you can share yourself, really give yourself to someone in ways you never even thought were possible before. Your mother must be thrilled."
“科技难道不不可思议吗？”曼迪说，“现在医生什么都能做。你现在可以分享自我，真正把自己给予某人，这是你以前从未想过可能的。你母亲一定欣喜若狂。”
"But it's crazy," I say.
“但这很疯狂，”我说。
She takes my hand in hers and looks up into my eyes. "Frankly, Arnie, I didn't think you had it in you. I'm really impressed. Really I am."
她拉起我的手，看着我的眼睛。“坦白说，阿尼，我没想到你会有这种勇气。我真的被感动了。真的。”
"Mandy, I thought you could be realistic about this. What about me? Do you want me dead? What am I supposed to do without a heart?"
“曼迪，我以为你会现实点。那我呢？你想要我死吗？没有心脏我要怎么活？”
"Oh, I'm sure they could fix you up. The important thing right now is to help your mother." She unzips my jacket and presses her hand against my chest. My heart twitches, flutters like a baby bird in her hands. "Arnie, you know what the right thing to do is. You should get back to your mother now." I watch her go, brisk, determined steps, like a schoolteacher.
“噢，我相信他们肯定能帮你修好的。现在最重要的是救你母亲。”她拉开我的夹克拉链，把手贴在我的胸口。我的心抽动着，像她手中的小鸟一样扑腾。“阿尼，你知道正确的事情是什么。你现在该回到你母亲身边了。”我看着她离开，步履轻快而果断，就像个女教师。
I find my way back to the waiting room. Someone has mopped up the coffee. "Feel better?" Nina asks. "Made a decision yet?" Fran says.
我回到了候诊室。有人已经把咖啡拖干净了。“感觉好点了吗？”尼娜问。“做出决定了吗？”弗兰说。
"Yes. No. I don't know," I say. They are both quiet. Fran turns to me. "Arnie, think about this. The heart's a little thing, really. Less than a pound. It's just a muscle. You've got muscles all over the place. Can't you spare one?" She looks earnestly into my face. "Can't you spare a little bit of flesh?" And then they are crying, both of them, drops sliding down the wrinkles in their faces.
“是的。不。我不知道，”我说。她们俩都沉默了。弗兰转向我：“阿尼，想一想。心脏是个小东西，真的。不到一磅重。它只是块肌肉。你身上到处都是肌肉。就不能分出来一点吗？”她真诚地盯着我的脸，“就不能分出一小块血肉吗？”然后她们开始哭，两个人都在哭，泪水顺着脸上的皱纹流下来。
Later we go visit my mother again. She looks worse, but perhaps it's the fluorescent lights. I stand again at the foot of her bed. I can see the veins and tendons on her neck. So delicate, so close to the surface you could snip them with scissors.
后来我们又去探望母亲。她看起来更糟了，但也许是日光灯的原因。我再次站在床脚。我能看到她脖子上的静脉和筋腱。那么脆弱，那么靠近表面，只要用剪刀就能剪断。
"Arnie," she says softly, "you should go home and get some sleep. And shave. You look terrible. So tired. Go. I'll be here tomorrow. I'm not going anywhere."
“阿尼，”她轻声说，“你应该回家睡一觉。还有刮刮胡子。你看上去糟透了。太累了。去吧。我明天还在。哪儿也不会去。”
I drive home in the dark. I go up to my apartment and turn on the lights. I want to call Mandy. Then I realize I don't want to call her at all. Usually my mother calls in the evening and tells me about TV programs and weather changes.
我开车回家，陷入黑暗中。我上楼进公寓，打开灯。我想给曼迪打电话。然后我意识到我根本不想给她打电话。通常我母亲会在晚上打来，跟我讲电视节目和天气变化。
I turn off the lights and sit in the dark. I look at the ceiling, at the smoke detector. It has a blue light that pulses with a regular beat, like the blip on a cardiograph.
我关掉灯，坐在黑暗中。我看着天花板，看着烟雾探测器。它有一个蓝灯，伴随着规律的节奏闪烁，就像心电图上的闪点。
Early the next morning at the hospital, I tell the doctor, "I want to do it. Give her my heart." He gives me a long, steady look, eyes huge behind the glasses. "I think you've made the right decision. I do," he says. His eyes drop to my chest. "We can get started right away."
第二天清晨在医院，我告诉医生：“我想做。把我的心脏给她。”他长久而坚定地看着我，眼镜后的眼睛很大。“我觉得你做出了正确的决定。真的，”他说。他的视线落在我的胸口，“我们可以立刻开始。”
"But what about a transplant for me?" I say. "Don't you need to arrange that first?"
“但我呢？给我移植的事怎么办？”我说，“你不必先安排好那个吗？”
"Oh, we'll take care of that when the time comes. I want to get your heart into your mother right away before, before--"
“噢，时候到了我们会处理的。我想立刻把你母亲的心脏移植好，在……在……”
"Before I change my mind?" I say. He hardly hears. He's already deep in his plans. He claps me on the back. "Have you told your mother yet? Well, go tell her. And then we'll get your chest shaved and get started."
“在我改变主意之前？”我说。他几乎没听见。他已经深陷在计划中。他拍了拍我的背，“告诉你母亲了吗？去告诉她吧。然后我们就把你的胸部刮干净开始。”
This is what I have realized. All along, I thought I'd publish a book, lots of books. Get recognition. Earn lots of money. Support my mother in style in her old age. Give her gorgeous grandchildren. I thought that was the way to pay her back for everything I owe her.
我终于意识到这一点。一直以来，我想的是出版一本书，很多书。得到认可。赚很多钱。在母亲晚年时让她过上奢华的生活。给她生漂亮的孩子。我以为那是回报我对她所欠一切的方式。
But now it looks like I have to pay my debts with my heart instead. Under these circumstances, I don't have a choice. I'm almost glad. It seems easier this way. I'll just give her a piece of muscle, and then I'll be free of her forever. All my debts paid. One quick operation will be so much easier than struggling for the rest of my life to do back to her all the things she thinks she's done for me. It seems like a good bargain.
但现在看来，我必须用我的心来还债。在这种情况下，我别无选择。我甚至有点高兴。这样似乎更容易。我只要给她一块肌肉，然后我就永远解脱了。所有的债都还清了。一次快速的手术比为了偿还她认为她为我做过的一切而终生挣扎要容易得多。这看起来是个不错的交易。
When I tell my mother the news, she cries a little, and smiles, and says, "Oh, I didn't expect it. Oh, not for a minute. I wouldn't expect such a sacrifice from you, Arnie. I wouldn't dare to even mention such a thing. It's more than any mother could expect of her son. I'm so proud of you. I guess I did a good job of raising you after all. You've turned into such fine, good person. I worried that I may have made mistakes when I was bringing you up. But now I know I didn't."
当我告诉母亲这个消息时，她哭了一会儿，微笑着说：“噢，我没指望。噢，一分钟也没想过。我绝不会指望你做出这种牺牲，阿尼。我甚至不敢提这种事。这超出任何母亲对儿子的期望。我真为你感到骄傲。看来我确实养育得很成功。你已经长成了一个如此优秀、善良的人。我曾担心我在抚养你时犯了错误。但现在我知道我没有。”
On and on she goes. And the aunts, they cry, clutch my arms, not so tight as before. And they say they'd doubted me, but they never will again. "What a good son," they keep saying. Looking at them now, they seem smaller than they did before. Shriveled.
她一直不停地说。阿姨们也在哭，抓着我的胳膊，不像以前那么紧了。她们说曾经怀疑过我，但再也不会了。“多好的儿子，”她们不停地重复。现在看着她们，她们看起来比以前更小了。萎缩了。
I call Mandy and she dashes over to the hospital. She kisses all over my face with her cherry-flavored ChapStick. She hugs me, presses her ear against my chest. She tells me she knew I'd do the right thing.
我给曼迪打电话，她冲到医院。她用樱桃味润唇膏在我脸上吻来吻去。她拥抱我，把耳朵贴在我的胸口。她告诉我她就知道我会做正确的事。
I'm feeling pretty good now. I light up a cigarette. She takes it away from me and mashes it beneath her heel. "That belongs to your mother now," she says.
我现在感觉很棒。我点上一支香烟。她把它从我手里拿走，踩在脚下碾碎。“那已经是你母亲的了，”她说。
They all give me flowers. I feel like a hero. I kiss my mother's cheek. I hop on a stretcher. They wheel me out. They sedate me slightly, strip me, shave me. And then they put the mask on and knock me out good.
她们都送我花。我觉得自己像个英雄。我吻了母亲的面颊。我跳上担架。他们把我推了出去。他们给我轻微镇静，脱掉我的衣服，刮掉我的体毛。然后戴上口罩，把我彻底麻醉。
It's like I'm falling, falling down a deep well. And the circle of daylight above me grows smaller and smaller and smaller until it is a tiny white bird, swooping and fluttering against a vast night sky.
感觉像是坠落，坠入一口深井。我头顶的圆圈日光变得越来越小，越来越小，直到变成了一只微小的白鸟，在广阔的夜空中俯冲扑腾。
How does it feel to have no heart? It feels light, hollow, rattly. Something huge is missing. It leaves an ache, like the ghost of a severed limb. I'm so light inside but so heavy on the outside. Like gravity increased a hundredfold, gravity holding me to the bed like the ropes and pegs of a thousand Lilliputians.
没有心脏是什么感觉？感觉很轻，空虚，甚至有种碰撞声。有些巨大的东西缺失了。它留下了一阵疼痛，像是一个被截断的肢体的幻觉。我的内心如此轻盈，但外部却沉重无比。像是重力增加了百倍，重力像绑住格列佛的绳索和钉子一样把我压在床上。
I lie at the bottom of a pool. Up above I see the light on the surface. It wavers, ripples, breaks, and comes together again. I can see the people moving about, far above in the light. I am down here in the dark, cradled in the algae. Curious fish nibble my eyelashes.
我躺在一个池底。在上方，我看到水面的光。它摇曳、荡漾、破碎，然后重新聚拢。我能看到人们在光亮中高高地走动。我在这黑暗中，蜷缩在水藻里。好奇的鱼儿啃着我的睫毛。
After a while, I see a smooth, pink face above me. The doctor? "Arnie," he says. "The operation went very well. Your mother is doing wonderfully. She loves the new heart."
过了一会儿，我看到上方一张光滑、粉红的脸。是医生吗？“阿尼，”他说，“手术非常成功。你母亲恢复得很好。她很爱这颗新心脏。”
His words begin far away and drift closer, growing louder and louder until they plunk down next to me like pebbles. "Arnie," he calls. The pool's surface shivers. His face balloons, shrinks to a dot, then unfolds itself. "Arnie, about you. We're having a little trouble. There is a shortage of spare hearts in the country right now. We're looking for some kind of replacement. But don't worry. You'll be fine."
他的声音从远方传来，逐渐飘近，越来越响，直到像石子一样掉落在我的身边。“阿尼，”他呼唤着。池面颤抖。他的脸像气球一样膨胀，又缩成一个点，然后展开。“阿尼，关于你。我们遇到了一点麻烦。现在国内缺少备用心脏。我们正在寻找某种替代方案。但别担心。你会没事的。”
Later, I see Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina. They lean close. They're huge. Their faces bleed and run together like wet watercolors. "Your mother's doing so well," they call. "She loves you. Oh, she's so excited. She'll be in to see you soon."
后来，我看到了弗兰阿姨和尼娜阿姨。她们凑得很近。她们太巨大了。她们的脸像湿水彩一样晕染开来。“你母亲做得很好，”她们呼喊着，“她很爱你。噢，她太兴奋了。她很快就会来看你的。”
And later it's my mother gliding in, her face pink, her hair curled. "Arnie, Arnie, you good boy," she calls. And then they wheel her out.
后来母亲飘了进来，脸庞红润，头发卷曲。“阿尼，阿尼，好孩子，”她叫着。然后他们把她推走了。
They leave me alone for a long time. I lie in the deep. It sways me like a hammock. There is a deep, low humming all around, like whales moaning. My mother does not visit again.
他们留我独自待了很久。我躺在深渊里。它像吊床一样摇晃着我。四周有低沉的嗡嗡声，像鲸鱼的哀鸣。母亲再也没有来过。
Alone in the dark, no footsteps, no click of the light switch. Then a doctor looms above me. "Your mother," he says, "is not doing well. The heart does not fit as well as we thought. It's a bit too small." He turns away and leans over again. "As for you, we're working on it. There is nothing available at the moment, but don't you worry."
孤独地待在黑暗中，没有脚步声，没有灯开关的咔嗒声。然后医生出现在我上方。“你母亲，”他说，“情况不太好。心脏不像我们想的那样匹配。有点太小了。”他转过头又俯下身，“至于你，我们正在想办法。目前还没什么可用的，但别担心。”
And then Fran and Nina are back. "How could you?" they scream, their voices shattering the surface into fragments. "Giving your mother a bad heart. How could you? What kind of son are you? She's dying. Your mother's dying, all because of you." They weep together.
然后弗兰和尼娜又回来了。“你怎么能这样？”她们尖叫着，声音将池面击成碎片，“给你母亲一颗坏心脏。你怎么能这样？你是哪种儿子？她快死了。你母亲快死了，都是因为你。”她们抱头痛哭。
For a long time, no one comes. I know without anyone telling me that my mother is dead. It is my heart. When it ceases to beat, I know.
很长一段时间，没有人来。不用任何人告诉我，我就知道母亲死了。那是我的心。当它停止跳动时，我就知道了。
The doctor comes to tell me how sorry he is. "She was doing so well at first. But then it turned out the heart just wasn't enough. I tell you, though, she was thinking of you when she died. She asked for you." He sits quietly for a moment.
医生来告诉我他有多遗憾。“她起初恢复得很好。但后来发现心脏还是不够用。但我告诉你，她临死前一直在想你。她叫你的名字。”他安静地坐了一会儿。
"We haven't managed to find a heart for you, but you'll be fine. We've shot you up full of preservatives. You'll stay fresh for a while yet." He goes away.
“我们没能为你找到心脏，但你会没事的。我们给你注入了大量的防腐剂。你还能保持新鲜一段时间。”他走开了。
Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina no longer visit. Mandy? Gone. I lie, listening to the emptiness in my chest, like wind wailing through canyons.
弗兰阿姨和尼娜阿姨再也不来了。曼迪？走了。我躺着，听着胸腔里的空洞，就像风在峡谷中哀号。
These days the doctor comes in often to chat with me. One day he tells me a story. "You know, when your mother died, we managed to save your heart. It was still healthy. We thought about giving it back to you, but there was this little girl here, about eight years old. She needed a new heart too. Cute little blond girl. One time a basketball star came in here to visit, and there were TV cameras and photographers and everything. She was in the papers a lot. Kids were always sending her cards.
最近医生经常来跟我聊天。有一天他讲了一个故事。“你知道吗，你母亲去世时，我们设法保住了你的心。它依然健康。我们想过把它还给你，但这里有个8岁左右的小女孩。她也需要一颗新心脏。可爱的金发女孩。有次一位篮球明星来这里访问，电视摄像师和摄影师到处都是。她在报纸上出现了很多次。孩子们总是寄卡片给她。”
"Anyway, we decided to give her your heart. She's only a kid, after all. She's got her whole life ahead of her. Why should we deny her that? I'm sure your mother would have wanted it that way. She was such a caring, selfless woman. I'm sure, deep down, you want her to have it too, don't you?"
“总之，我们决定把你的心脏给她。毕竟她还是个孩子。她还有整个人生在等着她。我们为什么要拒绝她呢？我相信你母亲肯定也希望这样。她是一个如此关怀、无私的女人。我相信，在内心深处，你也希望她能拥有它，不是吗？”
Of course I do.
我当然希望。
Judy Budnitz's short story "Guilt," from her collection of short stories called Flying Leap. Her latest book is Nice Big American Baby. Her story was read by actor Matt Malloy, who is in way too many movies to name here, but is available for your casting needs.
朱迪·巴德尼茨的短篇小说《内疚》，选自她的短篇小说集《飞跃》。她最新的书是《漂亮的大美国婴儿》。她的故事由演员马特·马洛伊朗读，他参演的电影多得数不过来，但可以接受你的选角邀请。
Chelsea Merz's story with Matthew came to us with help from Jay Allison and the Cape and Island NPR stations with support from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
切尔西·默茨与马修的故事是在杰·艾利森和海角与岛屿 NPR 电台的帮助下完成的，并得到了公共广播公司的支持。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our web site, where you can hear any of our programs for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，在那里您可以完全免费收听我们的任何节目：thisamericanlife.org。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. Our message to him today?
芝加哥 WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。我们今天给他的信息是：
We've shot you up full of preservatives. You'll stay fresh for a while yet.
我们给你注入了大量的防腐剂。你还能保持新鲜一段时间。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。